I felt like my insides had entirely
liquefied and just fell out of my body
and it was like that for weeks and
actually months after that so I actually
had two different situations where I was
pregnant and had an abortion the first
time was my freshman year in college it
was my first time taking birth control
and I just wasn't taking it properly
I've always kind of had an issue with
like hormones anything like that and
after trying several birth controls my
body just kind of went haywire I got to
the point where mentally it just wasn't
healthy for me anymore the second time I
was taking birth control the same time
every single day and I ended up getting
pregnant me and my fiancee at the time
decided to start like just using condoms
we weren't very consistent with it so we
just thought like pull out method and I
got pregnant anyway during both
situations I was with a partner it was
actually the same partner during the
first time that I was pregnant we were
dating when I found out that I was
pregnant it was as a result of an
ultrasound at a Gynaecologists previous
pregnancy scares what my mom had always
told me is that your nipples would be
really really sore I had gotten up and I
went straight to the shower and I could
not have water running directly on my
chest I was absolutely terrified the
second time was actually shortly after
we were married I missed my period I was
completely shocked the very first thing
that came to my mind was I can't do this
I was full-time school I had no health
insurance
and I mean we had no money I had no idea
how my anxiety meds would affect a baby
is terrifying I kind of knew even before
taking the test that if it were positive
I would have to get an abortion and it
wasn't really like a decision-making
process for me it was more talking my
partner into it he really did want to
keep the baby and I think ultimately he
did end up presenting that a little bit
the first abortion that I
walking into that abortion clinic was
scary it wasn't a welcoming environment
my partner wasn't able to come into the
room with me even just the room that I
was in itself felt really cold the day I
found out I was pregnant I had called
Planned Parenthood and I made an
appointment and I went in that day and
they told me my due date and my due date
was actually the day that we were
supposed to be getting married
they had me schedule my abortion date
and the next appointment was a week from
that day which fell on my birthday so
that was rough I didn't have a great
sense of exactly what to expect in terms
of the procedure the doctor buzzed into
the room he spoke really quickly didn't
give me the opportunity to actually
speak or respond back I just remember
him saying how are you doing what do you
like to do oh I know one thing you like
to do they have a little paper med cup
put just a pill in it and a glass of
water and they told me that I would just
take that pill and it'd be one of two
pills and it would begin the abortion
and then I'd be free to go I was you
know there by myself with this pill that
would change my life I was given general
anesthesia when I woke up later I could
tell that there were a lot of other
women around me who were in pain it was
the most excruciating pain I have ever
felt I felt like it was kind of a
penance for me when I got home I felt a
general sense of achiness
my body felt tired it was like menstrual
cramps times a thousand
it was like my insides were spasming
when I had my second abortion my partner
was by my side the entire time there was
no general anesthesia it was a gentle
aspiration method and afterwards I
actually had the option to be able to
see the fetus that was removed from my
body what I saw was a collection of
cells it looked like a jellyfish it was
this little pink spongy mass on a petri
dish this wasn't a viable life-form
outside of my own body
afterwards one of the things that I was
told was that I couldn't lift anything
heavy several days after I actually had
the abortion I was in a situation where
I had to carry something it wasn't even
that heavy maybe ten pounds later on
that evening I started bleeding I went
to the bathroom immediately and it was
like all of my insides fell out I don't
know how anybody could bleed that much
and live and it was like that for weeks
and actually months after that it became
really quickly apparent that the amount
that I was bleeding was abnormal and I
called the abortion clinic they were
able to send medication over to a
pharmacy the bleeding lasted for several
hours and once I was able to take the
medication very quickly after that it
stopped what I wasn't prepared for was
some of the emotional aftermath I was
basically just in my room for weeks and
weeks and weeks I started drinking
pretty heavily I couldn't stop thinking
about what if I hadn't made that
decision was absolute torture the
drinking got completely out of control
I felt a sense of depression I could not
be around my friends I could not go
anywhere without knowing that I would be
able to be drunk
my only source of support was my partner
we broke up about two months before the
wedding date and I had completely pushed
him out of my life like he was pretty
much just a roommate I felt like I
didn't fight hard enough for my baby and
then he didn't fight hard enough for me
once my wedding date came around I ended
up in a bathtub with a bottle of Jack
Daniel's crying too like the song that
we were supposed to dance to on our
wedding day in my wedding dress the very
dramatic and kind of ridiculous looking
back on it but at the time I felt like
it was the most poetic thing to do on
that day looking back on those decisions
I feel even more confident that they
were the right choice for me at that
time I don't have any regrets about
making the decision the only regret I
have was that I didn't reach out to
other people to talk about it because
that left me feeling really isolated I'm
still not completely back to myself if
I'm being completely honest physically
it kind of made my cramps worse I
believe more heavily during my periods
it's like every time my period would
come I'd be reminded of that whole
procedure I'm remarried I'm in a
relationship where I'm thinking about
having a child I realized that the same
concerns and the same thoughts that I
had then are still there every year on
that date I kind of put it a little bit
of time aside to kind of sit with myself
and think like this would have been my
baby's birthday they would have been
this old you know I'll write a letter in
my diary to the baby you know whatever
therapeutic thing I can do for myself
after getting sober I met my husband and
we're expecting our first child now I
know none of that would have happened
had I not made the decision that I did
being able to raise a child as
tremendously
difficult I know that now as a woman in
my 30 is that even when you're ready you
never feel like you're completely ready
to be carrying a child after choosing
not to carry another I feel that
apologetic you know weaves kind of come
with me that like I'm choosing to keep
this one and I didn't choose to keep the
other one and it's almost like I have to
apologize to like the idea of my first
baby I can't carry that guilt into this
pregnancy I didn't know what to expect
in the aftermath of an abortion I didn't
realize that I potentially could be
awash in emotions that were a result of
the hormones in my body
it doesn't necessarily get better it
just gets different your life will
change forever regardless of what
decision you make it's just learning to
have a different life after that that's
really important
[Music]